We'll have 5i, 3i root 2, 3i root 3 and 4i root 3. Great effort if you got at
least one of those correct. For the first one we simply take the square root of
25 which is 5 and the square root of negative 1 which equals i. For our second
one we'll split up negative 18 into 9 times 2. times the square root of
negative 1. We know the square root of 9 equals 3, and the square root of 2
needs to stay as the square root of 2, since 2 can't be simplified. We've
replaced the square root of negative 1, with i, leaving us with 3 times i root
2. We use similar thinking to get to this third one, we'll have 3i root 3. And
finally, for this last radical, we'll break up the square root of negative 48
into 16 times 3 times the square root of negative 1. We know the square root of
16 equals 4, and the square root of 3 stays as the square root of 3, since this
can't be simplified. We replace the square root of negative 1 with i and then
multiply 4 and i to get 4i root 3. Our final answer. There are of course other
ways to simplify this last expression this would be the quickest.